hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments mark now that you're a [ __ ] or
rooster to know what you were thinking
can you please demonstrate your
cockadoodledoo Ling Bing okay
Oh pop top of the morning to you laddies
how long are you gonna how long are you
gonna keep your hair dyed honestly I
have no idea I've really really liked
the red and black going on it works
really well for me and one of my friends
back home in Cincinnati told me that
it's the same color as the college I
used to go to good old University
Cincinnati or more appropriately the
college that I dropped out of university
of cincinnati oh ho Cho it's day but I
really really like it and it works for
me now but I imagine that I'll come
across a situation where I will need to
go back to my normal air color once I
enter normal society after YouTube I'm
in a very nebulous period where I have a
I'm very fortunate to have this job job
and I I'm doing this for a living but I
imagine once YouTube dies down and
whatever I transition to I'll probably
have to change back to more normal
colors whatever normal is can you please
tell us an embarassment story mark by
the way you're awesome
my awesome oh oh I've got so many
embarrassing stories basically my whole
life is in embarrassment but that's
besides the point and there's one part
that always sticks out as a kid because
it's when I was finally old enough to
realize that I did something really
really stupid and embarrassing and then
I developed crippling social anxiety
from that and realized that I would
never fit in okay there's a big
grandiose but here's the situation I was
in Korea I wasn't in Korea I was in
Hawaii with my family my mom was there
and we were travelling around the city
because I was born in Hawaii and she
wanted to go back and we were just
taking a vacation so we were wandering
around the streets and I ran ahead of us
walking in the streets and there's a lot
of Korean ladies in Hawaii just to
preface this so
I was running around and I got lost and
I got absent-minded I was about I don't
know like 11 at the time and I ran up to
who I thought was my mother and I
grabbed her by the hand and I looked at
her looked at her didn't even recognize
that it wasn't my mom looked her dead in
the eyes and was like hey can I have my
money and it was just like she had this
look of terrified expression oh who are
you demon child and why are you trying
to rob me this is a really young age to
try to steal my money and so like it
wasn't until my mom just like screamed
my name like mark I look back and
realize my whole family's there watching
me grab the hand of a mysterious
stranger lady who is purely terrified
and then I demanded money from her so it
was at that moment that I realized that
I wouldn't fit in total society and I
was not gonna be okay and if I couldn't
even realize that my own mom wasn't my
mom looking you're dead in the face then
I just wasn't gonna succeed in life and
so at that point I caved in on myself
emotionally I was my that was one
embarrassing story I've got many others
I'll tell them at a later date mark do
you know about the fanfiction with you
and Jack if so you should read one oh do
I know I'll pull one up right now place
your bets let's see what's gonna come up
first the phrase throbbing member or
pulsating organ Oh God no he's only huh
the sheet is a bit tented in that area
which gives me an idea
I slowly and carefully get the sheet off
of him he's only half hard I put on lube
on my fingers and prepare myself while
it then slowly ease me buried today with
a moan
anyway glad I could scar all of you for
life with that wonderful story mark do
you have a favorite cartoon or at least
a favorite theme song from a cartoon I
would have to say that my favorite
cartoon always has been and always will
be ed ed Nettie
I love a 10 Nettie but it's theme song
isn't exactly song ish it's not exactly
catchy it's like just a lot of whistling
and a lot of shouting randomly but the
one theme song that always has stuck in
my mind and I'm not good at remembering
these things is actually Jimmy neutrons
theme song I just recently watched a
video about it it's like a super-powered
mind a mechanical canine
bark-bark rescues the day from sure
destruction
it's Jimmy Neutron for some reason that
just always stuck out in my mind and I
didn't even really like that show very
much it was a good show don't get me
wrong but in the ranking of my favorite
cartoons of all time it's not exactly I
looking back and seeing the 3d animation
for what it was is hilariously bad at
this point but you know the Drake TV
shot of that at the time it's actually
pretty pretty impressive just not that
impressive now good show though ed
manatees still the best you are red but
the panels are blue I demand you change
that immediately oh yes everything
should be
do you plan on recording no man's sky
yes sir I'll give it a go I love space
and all that stuff and everyone seems to
be exploding about that game so sure I'd
love to give it a go I'd love to
adventure myself into the deepest
reaches of space and have a ton of fun
with it so yeah markiplier you should
really do a road trip semi-annually have
it be videogames improv singing whatever
you can think of I would do my best to
be there and watch actually I just had a
conversation with a select few people
just yesterday about this very subject
because as you know the game grumps are
doing a live show here in LA to try to
test the waters to see how it would be
to do a live show and I talked to them
about doing a tour and if I would ever
do a tour with some people that I would
love it would be one the game grumps it
would be to ninja sex party and their
friends Tupperware a remix party so
they're all planning to do something so
I would love to get a big show together
to take around the country and this is
all just planning phrases I'm not saying
this is an announcement that this is
gonna happen but if I had an ideal to do
it it would be to take the musical acts
of ninja sex party star bomb Tupperware
a remix party and then combine it with
like intermingled playing video games
with the game grumps and myself and a
few friends of mine and also doing
improv in between we could create a huge
like two to three hour show that we
could take around the country and that
would actually provide you guys
entertainment and be like you know
useful for you guys to come and see an
enjoyable and like a memorable
experience so that would be my ideal for
a touring road trip semi-annually so it
may be more realistic than you think
what instrument did you play in high
school
trumpet it was
if you have any wish and it can't be
more wishes what would it be oh now we
get an open-minded very deep question if
I had a wish and anything at all was
possible
i-i've always said this has been my one
wish that I would have for the rest of
eternity if I enter I ever had the
opportunity to have this one was granted
it would be to control time in all its
aspects and be like the master and Lord
of time not a Time Lord not like that
not the doctor I don't want to be the
doctor I just wish that I could be like
a manipulator of time in every essence
with a mere thought I could make the ebb
and flow time reverse and reverse and
warp in shape and all that I sound a lot
like a Time Lord don't I that's not what
I wanted but that would be my wish well
your wish be right in the comments
whatever your wish would be okay is
there a way we can still send you stuff
unfortunately no and I always feel mean
when I say this but I don't have a peel
boxing board mostly because it was a
huge investment of time on my part it's
it takes forever and you guys don't
understand because of the scale at which
I got things and I had a peel box backs
when I had a few hundred thousand
subscribers which seems so long ago I
remember the apartment I used to do it
out of and that seems like ages and ages
ago and that's about three years ago now
and that's mind-blowing to think about
that but back then I couldn't keep up
with it I literally could not keep up
with it it was a huge investment of time
and now that I want to make sure that I
get my videos out right and I've got
other projects that I'm working on I've
got other things that I'm organizing
with other people I literally don't have
the time and also I don't think I'm
worthy of that stuff I like it sounds
weird but in a way I don't want you guys
to waste your time making me something
because I don't feel like it's worth
your time to make something for me I'm
not a very good present guy I don't like
to get presents even on my birthday I
never asked for anything and it's not
that I'm and maybe that sounds mean in
that way like I don't want it to sound
mean it's not a mean thing it's it's
that you guys are so talented and
everything
that you do and make is really cool I
want to make sure it's not wasted on a
loser like me I want to I want to
reiterate this point I love you guys and
I do care about the things that you make
and I I'm not saying that I don't like
what you guys make for me I really am
honored every time I see fan art and
stuff you know I'm honored that you guys
would even take the time to dedicate
your talents to make something for me
and I try to share that out as best I
can but I want to reiterate the point
I appreciate what you guys do for me and
I appreciate how you guys have supported
me every day and I know that some of you
guys need a creative outlet to make
something and like it's an inspiration
to make something about me I don't want
to discredit that in any way I am
literally just talking about getting a
mountain of material things and trying
to read through a thousand or more
letters like in a week like back when I
was doing it there was hundreds of
letters every week that I tried to open
and read and I always felt bad if I
wasn't able to get to him so I just had
to shut it all down because it was this
weird thing where people were getting
angry that I wasn't opening their stuff
and I just couldn't keep up with it it
was too many emotions and it was too
much time and I just have it I couldn't
handle it at the time I could not handle
it I could definitely not handle it now
for my own sanity and for you guys as
appreciation I couldn't handle the
entirety of love that you guys pour out
but I want to reiterate that I
appreciate everything you guys do and I
love you guys for all the support that
you put out and I'm glad that I'm able
to be a source of inspiration for you
guys and I just want to say
thank you for what you do not that I'm
unappreciative what you make I'm just
one guy just me and me alone and I can't
do much but thank you guys so much for
all the love and with that being said we
are all out of time for this reading
your comments thank you everyone one and
all for writing your comments down in
the comment section I really do
appreciate it I had a lot of fun reading
this and I'm sorry for the delay
there was so much stuff going last week
with Daniel's family and really thank
you everyone who gave a lot of goodwill
out to the kyer family and thank you for
everyone for their goodwill messages out
to them they really did appreciate it
they appreciate everything that you guys
have done for them and thank you for
giving them the opportunity to be a part
of my life and our lives and you know
just bringing us together even in the
face of tragedy I really do thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video